talk about the title to this album
that's coming man love for rent yeah
yeah love for rent um I caught that [ __ ]
love for rent because yeah I don't know
we're trying [ __ ] out that's where I
said right now we just try [ __ ] out love
for rent like
basically like it's really supposed to
be like the whole concept is what I told
without what I I already said this [ __ ]
but I'ma say it again the whole concept
is like ways that you feel me I give
love out
to the point where I have enough to get
that [ __ ] back to myself you feel me and
uh
I kind of wrote it from that perspective
but like I wasn't trying to be so like
um
what you call it uh
introspective about love more so just
honest about like my my real actions and
what I was doing in the time while I was
affected by that feeling if that makes
sense that makes sense yeah
so you gotta have that water yeah okay
always
got to stay hydrated man
huh
but yeah that's what love for rent about
that [ __ ] fire to me though it's real
fire it's a great name yeah yeah it's
real far outside of J Cole any other
features of course there are yeah we got
a whole lot of features uh actually a
lot of cool [ __ ] on the album
[Music]
um
give us one
can we get one one
give me a rapping ass [ __ ]
that's on your album a rap feature there
just a rapper someone who could rap
their ass off I know somebody's rapping
their ass off on that album
oh [ __ ] me
um and then uh I say Lil Uzi Uzi yeah
okay okay Uzi rapping on my [ __ ] I think
uzi's rapping around I think Uzi be
getting like not enough credit in terms
of like how good of your rap because he
could sing yeah he's singing and [ __ ] he
got like other ideas so I feel like you
know when you ain't no rapping ass this
is what I do I rap and I wanna rap
better than you ass [ __ ] people gonna
try to play that's me [ __ ] [ __ ]
be trying to play with me bro I promise
you everything I love I probably didn't
see it cold as [ __ ] than most [ __ ] but
I sang that [ __ ] so it come across like
you see me how they come across but yeah
how did you and Uzi link up
he liked my song I deserve he had posted
the balloons from the video and [ __ ] and
uh [ __ ] I just randomly was smoking
outside the studio I was in the studio
with uh saba and no ID
and I was outside smoking and [ __ ] this
[ __ ] black truck just pulled up damn
but like stop next to me then [ __ ]
jumped out this was this [ __ ] Uzi and
[ __ ] and he was in the room next to me
so he walked in the room and [ __ ] I went
in with him I was like bro I got this
song and I said your name in the hood
and played for you I played it for him
and he hopped on it I was leaving to go
uh go to a little dinner and [ __ ] before
I got out the Uber for dinner he he sent
me the song Jesus that [ __ ] did that
[ __ ] like 10 minutes [ __ ] wow it's hard
though I love how you just pass over
like you were in with no ID and you know
no ID is one of my favorite producers of
all time so shout out to no ID no idea
Sabo working on anything I was there you
were just there I was wrapping my ass
off in there too though yeah shout out
to shout out to no idea the coldest
thing about no idea is that this [ __ ]
named Dion and n-o-i-d it took me so
long to know that that's so hard it is
hard that [ __ ] genius it is genius
Chicago [ __ ] shout out to Chicago shout
out today
um who's on who's handling production on
this um any producers that you can shout
out I mean yeah Monty Booker my boy
groovy he did the uh Groove did this uh
90 proof that just came out yeah my boy
Felix Kyle Banks childish major
and myself them the producers it's all
it's all internal [ __ ] am I missing
somebody
yeah that's that's I think it's I think
that's yeah when you like can handle
some of your own production is it like
you know we think of some artists who
kind of came in the game as producers
and then there's guys like J Cole or
crit who like would have been doing both
kind of the whole time but like they're
more known as an artist would you ever
produce for other artists or like even
like oh you go down that Avenue where
you like make it a thing where you're
like pitching beats to like artists and
[ __ ] I wouldn't push be I mean
everybody's ever been in the studio with
me understand uh how what I do in the
studio you know what I'm saying so right
I think it'll be more of a thing where
I'm just like let's just lock in and see
what you trying to do let me let me try
to help help steer the ship on something
creatively with you yeah let's figure it
out that's right like I love working
with people in collabs I think I did
like 30 [ __ ] collabs last year I'm on
a lot of albums I've been out of town
it's crazy I kept going uh we was in
Atlanta New York wherever but everybody
on tour right now so I've been just
performing a bunch with the homies and
[ __ ] so that [ __ ] got me thirsty Couture
that got me back though you got a tour
coming up yeah yeah yeah
announcing soon
Loki uh any damn day now yeah we finna
announce it with the album and all that
are you headlining yeah but I'm doing
like a uh it's like a like a co-head
line Vibe you feel me it's gonna be lit
on the game when will this tour
announcement happen because by the time
by the time this interview comes out it
might already be out do you guys have a
date yeah yeah yeah let's go we're gonna
announce that [ __ ] real song I don't
really give a [ __ ] y'all do what y'all
want to do no I'm saying like you [ __ ]
gonna come through y'all said
y'all heard her first y'all heard there
first you don't matter bro but we finna
go crazy bro we're gonna be back on you
I don't know I'm just throwing names out
there I don't know I'm just I'm just I'm
just fishing you know what I'm saying